oh hey phillip what are you doing here
hey well i'm about to go into a meeting
with some state legislators uh well so i
got stanley to cover those meetings for
you because i have another job for you
to do
okay you might want to change your
clothes
[Music]
hello hi i'm matt hey i'm phil how old i
understand you're my new hire for for
now i guess so all right all right look
you ready to get to work yes sir let's
go all right
these are some good cows
you want
you want to stay between the back legs
okay and keep your fingers off these
pipes
okay when she kicks
her hawk
spray this on to clean the cow and we'll
dry it off and put the melting unit on
all right
just
prior to sunker down
and then you move to the next cow okay
you want to try this one sure
you don't have to touch the couch
just prayer from the distance
so you'll get kicked and she hit you
right here okay so you never put
yourself just go
all right
when i first heard that the government
affairs
uh worker was coming out to
to be my employee for the day i was very
skeptical
i'll have to admit
i'd give him high scores on his his
dress he looked the part
he's a little too clean
you could use some paper towels all
right
and now we're just going to
dry
they're cleaner in the process of drying
raw
you get about two towels
and just gently dry her off
and get clean like
that all right
go ahead and reach in there you're okay
go ahead she's not kicking
i might dance a little kid
[Music]
okay that's pretty good we're gonna get
a little drier now
[Music]
i was hoping to learn a lot about what
our dairy farmers do in arkansas
and uh i've learned a lot about that
and
um
you know just get my hands dirty
get those were my expectations and i got
them dirty a couple of reasons to dry
them off one's to disinfect the other to
have a clean location to pull the milk
from
and two is to for cow health you want
the utter dry okay while the machine's
honored
pockets
[Music]
and it'll do its job
so how many uh how many gallons would
you get what do you usually get from
each cow
um
about eight gallons per cow per day how
many cows do you all do in a day about
180 and twice a day
you get half your milk in the morning
half in the afternoon
with your your left hand and dry hair
easily
how's that yeah you got that one pretty
good
all right
just throw your towels in the bucket
and you push the button to release
it
[Music]
just like you guys turn it
around oh god
[Music]
oh that one
you gotta hang your black oh yeah
look in this chain
[Music]
so i will say milking the cow was uh
more automated than i thought it would
be you know once
matt showed me how everything works you
know just making sure i put everything
in the right places and don't get hit by
the cow or don't have anything
drop on you
uh once i understood that process it
seemed very straightforward
oh yeah she left you a present
she was she left the presents for you oh
thank you thank you now the trick is to
dodge it
did i roll up my sleeve for this one
[Music]
i think i found my new job guys
sorry stanley
i think this is the business for me
we have to increase our speed or we
won't get to milk twice today
when deal when's the first time y'all do
it in the day well you started four in
the morning oh i changed my mind i like
my job now
[Music]
oh
and then
there's that thing all right
a particular reason why y'all do it at
uh those times of the day
it takes you about three hours to milk
so you want to get done in the afternoon
at a reasonable time
so you have to start early enough to get
finished
do you take naps in between
at night
you know so when y'all get all this milk
where does it go
got a refrigerated storage tank in the
other room
as it's coming out of the couch going
into this small tank
and as it fills it automatically pumps
with the storage tank okay storage tanks
refrigerator
and then yeah somebody come pick it up
yes the marketing clock comes every two
to three days to pick the milk up okay
haul at the market
but see it's coming out of the couch
body temperature
21.5 degrees
for a cow
and two hours after it comes out of the
cow we'll have it down to 36 degrees
okay
the milk comes through stainless steel
pipelines
and goes into the refrigerated tank
you can hear the tanks running right now
and it's already cooled to melt down to
it's 38 degrees okay
okay you go up and inspect the milk that
you fly
what's good to me
maybe take a milk bath
anybody ever fallen in
no from time to time you don't have to
go in and clean it oh is that what you
have your sons for well unfortunately i
get to do that
[Music]
[Applause]
um you can see the stalls
hence the barn gets its name free stall
the stalls don't have gates on them the
cows are free to come and go
they've got water
on the outside in the center they can
have access to at all times and they've
got feed in front of them all the time
so
the cows that you just milked
came back down here
and they're in in their living
environment
after we got started with the milking
process
showed him what we expected
and how to perform the task
after monitoring the task for the day on
a scale of one to ten i'd have to give
him about a six
well uh you know i enjoyed what i did
today but i think i'll leave the milken
up to the professionals these guys know
what they're doing
but me on the other hand i'm happy to go
back to the capitol and advocate for
these guys make sure they can stay in
business and so that their children can
keep doing it
it's important to keep our dairy farms
here in arkansas well matt thanks for
having me out here i was really excited
to learn about what y'all are doing uh
everything you told me when in one ear
and out the other
[Music]
anyway sorry
such a bad joke
[Applause]
[Music]